laughing all day especially after dark
okay if you're walking down Las Vegas
Boulevard so let's welcome Kelsey
Borland and Robert E Lee of the last
after dark Comedy Festival to explain
that there are some birds in the studio
if you hear loud loud noise we'll get to
that later
um now I'm sure Las Vegas has given
y'all a ton of material through here
absolutely yes yes I bet now it's coming
October 3rd through the 5th but first
before we get to that let's talk about
laugh after dark what is that what does
that mean so Life After Dark is our TV
show we started in Los Angeles in 2018
we filmed our first two seasons there
and we were getting ready to film our
third season on March 19 2020 so as we
all know the date that lives in infamy
and so what ended up happening is we
re-emerged here in Vegas and we were
able to film our entire 13 episode
season which will be coming out on 2B
and Amazon here shortly down on Fremont
Street and we had a really great about a
little over a year that we were down
there doing our show every week it was
really fun that is so congratulations
thank you that is amazing and obviously
resilient coming after that you know
Infamous date
um now it's obviously a special
connection to Las Vegas why the city is
perfect for the Comedy Fest right oh
absolutely yeah so let's talk about the
Comedy Fest Robert oh my gosh we're
gonna have three days of just all things
comedy we're gonna start off doing some
film screenings at uh Vegas uh Theater
Company and and all through the night
we're going to have a lot of showcases
and we're filming several uh comedy
specials there as well so that's going
to be so exciting and then what about
the local comedians will they be
involved oh absolutely names you could
throw out there that people could
recognize absolutely so we love Vegas we
love our local comics and so we actually
have them being our hosts for all of the
showcases okay so as Robert was saying
our showcases range forever there's
something for everyone so we have clean
comedy we have alt comedy we have extra
dark comedy regular Club comedy we've
literally got it all so it's going to be
a really great time and all of our local
Vegas Comics Stoner Rob Joslyn sharp
tricks they're all going to be hosting
those showcases so we're really excited
about this now forget about Gabe Lopez
oh yes there we go 30 at 12 30. there we
go he's actually hosting a showcase
called Dirty after dark wow dirty
and then there's a special really
special event for one of the comics as
well right he'll talk about the flagship
yes the flagship event for The Comedy
Fest is going to be the world premiere
of Khalia McNeil's debut comedy special
spam we were on tour this summer when we
had to CL when we shut down our show we
ended up going on tour and we were in
Santa Monica where we filmed her so
we're going to be having the red carpet
the whole nine we're gonna be screening
the show and then afterwards we're doing
a panel where we can people can interact
with us and with Kalia and ask questions
so we're really excited about that
that's so cool so it's not just industry
people it's everybody who is a fan of
Comedy wants to laugh Good Vibes learn a
little something about the film industry
too absolutely yeah so where can people
get tickets you can find all information
at laugh afterdark.com there's also
discounts on there for your passes as
well
um and we yeah we just can't wait we
want to invite all of Vegas out that's
huge for us because we're actually
hosting it in the arts district and
that's such an amazing part of Vegas
with some of the best foods so we're
partnering up with makers and finder the
Cornish pastico Taco Terrian and we just
can't wait to Spotlight our favorite
part of Vegas